you've likely heard by now that the
world economic Forum wants to make you
eat bugs live in a pod and owe nothing
and all of that is true but the wef is
taking some more immediate and concrete
steps to upend your life one such power
play is something called Safety by
Design which is probably the biggest big
tet threat that you have never heard of
safety by Design is the hobby horse of a
woman named Julie Inman Grant she's just
a bureaucrat she's the Australian
e-safety commissioner who went viral
last year in Davos at the world economic
Forum when she proposed a recalibration
of free speech
we are finding ourselves in a place
um where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere and everything
feels binary when it doesn't need to be
so I think we're going to have to think
about a recalibration of a whole range
of human rights that are playing out
online you know from freedom of speech
to the freedom to you know to be free
from online violence or the right of
data protection to the right to child
dignity
since then Grant has taken significant
steps in collaboration with the wef to
make their recalibration a reality
safety by Design is the notion that
government Regulators can't possibly
keep up with all the bad things
confronting people online
not just real problems like criminal
threats and fraud and child pornography
and things like that but a much broader
array of topics and opinions that
leftists deem harmful so these safety by
Design solution is to take the burden of
suppressing those things off of The
Regulators out of the government
agencies and just build liberals
regulatory preferences into the design
code of the tech platforms themselves
here's how it works
safety by Design to me is key this is
putting the responsibility back it's
it's it's having companies
um from the leadership from the top down
prioritize safety build it in at the
front end and
um
you know now we have the basic Online
safety expectations which basically lay
out the duty of care and what we respect
the interactive services to be doing as
a right to or a license to operate in
our country
so in order to operate in Australia
they've they've got to build the liberal
regulatory preferences into the code of
the platforms otherwise the platforms
don't get to operate in Australia but
safety by Design is not merely being
implemented in Australia because Grant
serves on a bunch of boards for the wef
and her plan in perfect alignment with
the broader globalist goals of Davos is
to export this scheme all around the
world to control speech in all sorts of
categories
not just the threats and the fraud and
the porn and media entertainment even
Sports
through safety by Design Grant and the
wef intend and have been open about
their intent to push diversity equity
and inclusion
to suppress what they call
misinformation and hate speech all of
which is gobbledygook talk for censoring
conservatives and promoting liberals and
if they can convince just a handful of
countries to implement these sorts of
policies
that could tip the scales to force big
Tech's hand to implement it for everyone
it's not that you need to convince every
country in the world to adopt this stuff
if you convince a few of them frankly
even if you just convince one of them
that is going to send a signal to Big
Tech to say okay look we're not going to
build completely separate platforms for
Australia and let's say Canada and the
US and France and then separate separate
platforms for all the rest of the
countries so okay we'll do what
Australia wants us to do and then safety
by Design governs the speech for
everybody people are posting all sorts
of conspiracy theories to social media
as the wef's annual meeting goes on in
Davao Switzerland right now
but if the globalists get their way
we won't see those conspiracy facts
online for much longer all sorts of
conspiracy theories here this here's a
conspiracy theory
this comes from AP News
AP news says says the world economic
Forum which opens Monday
is slated to take on pressing Global
issues but online
it has become a target of bizarre claims
from a growing chorus who believe it
involves a group of Elites manipulating
events for their own benefit we'll put a
pause right there
yes there are right-wingers who say that
about the world economic forum
that is what the world economic Forum
says about itself that is the entire
raison d'etre of the world economic
forum is to gather Global Elites to
change the world to become masters of
the future that's what Klaus Schwab says
the founder and
king of the world economic forum
it's it's a conspiracy fact it is a
theory about a conspiracy but the
conspiracy is real and so the the libs
are very upset about this they say this
isn't a conspiracy that's playing out on
the extreme fringes that's according to
Alex friedfeld a researcher with the
Anti-Defamation League who studies
anti-government extremism we'll put a
pause right there the Anti-Defamation
League isn't that the group that that
talks about anti-semitism
and accuses people that they don't like
of anti-Semitism why are they now
talking about
Davos why are they not talking about the
world economic form why are they upset
when people point out that we don't want
to eat the bugs and live in the pods and
and have all our property taken away by
Cloud Schwab who's not a Jew he's a
German
he says this is very very bad this is
we're seeing this
on mainstream social media platforms
being shared by regular Americans we
were seeing it being spread by
mainstream media figures right on their
Prime Time news on their nightly
networks oh no
Tara it's a crazy conspiracy theory
I mentioned on the show yesterday if you
say that Davos is where the elites get
together to completely transform society
and change the future
and that's a good thing
then you're a good wonderful person
you're insightful you keep up with the
news if you say the exact same thing
but you conclude it with
and that's a bad thing then you're a
crazy Fringe wild conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones you got the the tinfoil hats
on you probably worry about Chemtrails
and gay frogs
that's it's what Michael Anton at the
Claremont Institute calls the
celebration Parallax the the libs are
allowed to tell you their plans
and celebrate it but you can repeat to
them the very things that they just told
you if if you were going to criticize it
that's one tactic one tactic that the
libs have been using to downplay what's
going on in Davos is to say well this is
just a crazy conspiracy theory then the
other tactic that they've used and it's
really only started this year
is they say oh that's stuff that's going
on in Davos it's not a big deal I saw a
headline but I think it was in CNN so
the real story of what's going on in
Davos is the world economic Forum it's
actually losing its influence yeah
people don't they don't care about that
anymore it's not
it's not a big you guys are worried
about some crazy conspiracy theory not
the real real stories they're they have
way less power than they ever did
I don't know
2700 bigwig attendees from 130 countries
116 billionaires and 52 heads of state
and they don't have any power
I don't know
the mainstream media The Establishment
press seem real eager these days to play
Down the influence of Davos but you just
heard one example just one and this is
one little tiny example of how the wef
operates it brings together influential
people who all have the same liberal
left-wing Progressive agenda then they
all trade influence and they all work on
each other's power and its people in the
private sector and in the government
sector the point of Davos is to bring
those two sectors together
because if you bring those two sectors
together then sometimes the private
sector can do the Dirty Work of the
government and people have no recourse
against the private sector this is what
happens when the government uses
allegedly private corporations like
Facebook Twitter and Google to to censor
Americans Well it can't be a First
Amendment violation if the FBI just had
a secret meeting with some Facebook exec
and said hey censor censor the hunter
Biden laptop story
I mean I think it is a First Amendment
violation but they have plausible
deniability they say no it's a private
company private company has no First
Amendment responsibility to protect your
speech but really it's the government
that was pressuring the social media
companies
or you will see corporate influence onto
the government
pushing massive deregulation not for the
small business owners not for the mom
and pops for all the people who are in
the rooms at Davos
that you see it play out in real time
some random Australian bureaucrat
through the power that she wields among
liberal globalist networks is currently
in the process of changing the way
that the internet operates on
potentially the biggest platforms on the
internet
to decide what things you're allowed to
say to ban hate speech are you going to
be allowed to say in five years are you
going to be allowed to say on the
internet that a boy is a boy and a girl
is a girl maybe you're barely allowed to
say it now
but no they they have no influence what
do you pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain
foreign
[Music]